willst du mal Erfinderin nein Ingenieur
nein was dann
Steuerberater
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute gibt es einen der weltbesten
Schokoladenkuchen der Welt der ist so
mega saftig schokoladig und lecker
dieses Rezept möchte ich euch nicht
vorenthalten der ist einfach nur gut ich
zeige euch mal die Zutaten die ihr für
den Teig braucht sind doch gar nicht
viele und zwar braucht ihr dafür 250g
Butter 150 g Zartbitterschokolade dann
nehmt ihr auch wirklich eine gute
Qualität weil dann der Kuchen besser
schmeckt fünf Eier 120 Gramm Zucker eine
Prise Salz etwas Vanilleextrakt 40 Gramm
Mehl plus Backpulver oder ihr nehmt das
backmehl und 40 Gramm Kakao wichtig ist
dass ihr wirklich eine gute Schokolade
nehmt wie ich schon gesagt habe eine
Zartbitterschokolade denn wenn ihr jetzt
hier Vollmilch nehmt wird der Kuchen
nicht schokoladig genug in
Zartbitterschokolade ist einfach viel
Kakaoanteil etwas weniger Zucker und
umso dunkler und schokoladiger schmeckt
da eben auch was auch wichtig ist dass
ich weiß es ist wenig Mehl im Kuchen
dafür aber viel f aber deswegen ist er
eben auch so schön saftig also ein Tod
muss mal sterben gell entweder nehmt ihr
einen Kuchen einen Rezept mit mehr Mehl
und weniger Fett oder halt andersrum
jedenfalls wollen wir das sehr schön
saftig wird und deswegen machen wir das
so und ihr könnt das ganze auch gerne
glutenfrei zubereiten nehmt einfach ein
glutenfreies Mehl dazu und dann habt ihr
da auch ein perfektes Rezept so jetzt
gehen wir mal erstmal die ganze Packung
Butter hier rein und die Schmelze ich
jetzt entweder im Topf oder in der
Mikrowelle kurz
hier jetzt einfach nur drauf achten dass
die Butter nicht zu heiß wird also nicht
bei höchster Stufe sondern ich habe
jetzt bei mir geht's bis Stufe 9 und ich
habe jetzt Stufe 5 schalt aber
vielleicht sogar gleich noch runter denn
es soll nicht ganz heiß werden wegen der
Schokolade gleich dann habe ich hier
schon mal eine Backform die zeige ich
euch gleich und kann hier aber in der
Zwischenzeit weil ich eine
Küchenmaschine benutze die Zeit nutzen
die ich jetzt nicht am Herd stehe und
die Eier mit Zucker Salz und
Vanilleextrakt schön cremig verrühren
[Musik]
ich wollte gerade Vorarbeiten und schon
mal für die Glasur Zutaten abwägen und
dann lasse ich einfach die Glasschüssel
mit Schokolade fallen ins Waschbecken
der spritzt wieder zurück schneidet mich
hier und hier in die Hand
jetzt haben wir gerade die große Sauerei
weggemacht ach meine Güte jetzt sehe ich
so aus naja alles gut die Eier
Zuckermasse ist jetzt schön cremig hat
jetzt ein paar Minuten länger gerührt
bis ich aufgeräumt habe hier habe ich
Schokolade und die kommt jetzt zur
Butter und schmilzt einfach in der
Restwärme
soll jetzt nämlich gar nicht so heiß
sein sondern einfach nur lauwarm und
falls euch die Butter zu heiß geraten
ist gerne einfach umfüllen und dann die
Schokolade drin schmelzen
[Musik]
und die Masse kann ich jetzt hier dazu
geben und langsam einrühren
kann das hier weg
edelstahlrührelemente dürfen auch immer
gerne in die Spülmaschine
und dann kann ich jetzt Kakao mehl und
Backpulver dazu geben und schön 7 das
backmehl müsste ich jetzt nicht sieben
weil es einfach schön fein ist aber
Kakao macht immer so kleine Klümpchen
das muss auf jeden Fall gesiebt werden
ohne Deckel geht es auch besser
[Musik]
und das jetzt vorsichtig unterheben
dann habe ich jetzt hier meine Backform
und weil der Teig ja wirklich sehr
flüssig ist ist jetzt wichtig dass ihr
euren Tortenring entweder mit Backpapier
einschlagt damit es nicht ausläuft oder
nehmt eben diese neuen springformböden
die sind nämlich dafür gedacht dass eben
gar kein Teig ein ausläuft bei Biskuit
zum Beispiel braucht man es nicht oder
bei Festen rührteigen auch nicht da
reicht es einfach auf diesen Backblech
mit Dauerbackfolie aber wenn sie eben
dann doch flüssiger sind könnt ihr jetzt
diese Springform Böden nehmen die haben
auch so einen dauerbackfolien Zuschnitt
dabei da eben perfekt von der Größe her
passt setzt da den Tortenring drauf und
dann läuft da nichts mehr aus und ihr
müsst eben kein Backpapier mehr
einschlagen denn ich weiß das Backpapier
einschlagen ist nicht immer jedem
gelungen und vor allem hat man dann doch
Backpapier was man wegschmeißt und so
eben nicht mehr weil es hat auch so eine
Dauerbackfolie ist
jetzt hier schön einfüllen und dann im
Ofen backen
[Musik]
der Ofen ist schon vorgeheizt auf 170
Grad ober Unterhitze da braucht der
Kuchen so etwa 35 bis 40 Minuten
Stäbchenprobe am Ende nicht vergessen
falls ihr einen Bosch Backofen habt
könnt ihr das auch gerne mit backsensor
backen dann einfach nur in den Backofen
reinschieben backsensor an einfach
eingeben Kuchen in Backform fertig da
müsste nicht mehr auf die Backzeit
achten nicht die Temperatur einstellen
und auch nicht die heizarte das macht
dann der Backofen ganz alleine und falls
ihr die Sallys Welt App habt oder die
homeconnect App könnt ihr jetzt auch
einfach auf mein Rezept gehen und aus
dem Rezept heraus die Einstellwerte an
den Backofen senden das geht auch
[Musik]
der Kuchen ist gebacken und abgekühlt
jetzt geben wir die Sahne hier rein und
die Hitze von der Sahne schmilzt dann
gleich die Schokolade und dass die
Schokolade nicht anbrennt machen wir den
Herd gleich aus
ich jetzt nicht besser erklären können
Ella mama kann ich das
weißt du worauf wir jetzt achten müssen
bei der Sahne wenn die kocht
was passiert denn bei Milch wenn sie
kocht was kann da passieren dass sie
überkocht weil die so hoch steigt
woran sehen wir jetzt gleich dass die
kocht weil die Blubberblasen
[Musik]
jetzt darfst du weitermachen so wie du
gesagt hast
jetzt gehen wir das hier rein Mama
müssen wir nicht den Herz ausmachen ich
habe ihn ausgemacht guck da steht nur
noch ein was heiß ist aber da ist aus
der ist nur noch an weil auf dem Herd
was anderes steht da drüben
wunderschön
[Musik]
mama
kann mich noch mal machen wenn ich 12
bin dann benutze ich das als Hintergrund
für mein Handy
oder für mein iPad wenn ich mein iPad
bald kriege
hallo ich wünsche mir so meine Lieben
Geburtstag gehen iPad auf Amazon
[Musik]
vielleicht bringt ihr das auch nicht
ewige Diskussion mit diesem iPad ich
spiele nur nicht dass ihr das habt warum
wollte noch zu jung dafür bist nein bin
ich nicht
Nina und Maja und so haben auch schon
die ewige Diskussion mit dem
Elektrogeräte und ich löse schon mal den
Kuchen raus der ist nämlich abgekühlt
wie du gesagt hast
was riecht besser
das riecht gut
weißt du warum wieso weil das noch warm
ist und da das Aroma jetzt schön in die
Nase kommt und hier ist halt der Kuchen
der ist schon abgekühlt aber wenn man
den gleich Anschneiden der riecht auch
gut
könnt ihr mal an warum ist der Kuchen
eigentlich so platt
richtig
ich habe doch gerade eben gesagt mach
keine Konkurse lassen
und schaut mal den Tortenring und die
Dauerbackfolie einfach jetzt nur spülen
und dann eben wieder benutzen
hey kann man das auch wegschmeißen nein
aber machen das manche Leute
mit der zauberfolie nicht
okay du darfst verteilen ja
ich schmeckt es Aroma ja
mama wann kommt die Greta mal wieder
warum lassen die mich eigentlich nie
mitspielen die sind halt schon älter als
Du an was liegt es
überlegen wir mal du lässt auch manchmal
die Sophia nicht mitspielen weil sie
jünger ist als du und Samira lässt dich
nicht mitspielen weil du jünger bist als
sie
darf ich dir noch einen Trick zeigen mit
der Palette
ab
muss die Soße runterlaufen muss nicht
sie kann natürlich aber ich finde es
schön wenn sie oben drauf bleibt
ist aber nicht schlimm alles gut guck
mal du kannst jetzt hierher gehen und so
machen so im Kreis dann kriegt man das
schon so einen schönen Wirbel hin okay
so ganz kurz was machen
WoW und Herz und das können wir ja
gleich hier abstreifen zum abschlecken
ja
und jetzt ein paar Kakao nimmst
obendrauf
aber nicht überall
auf eine Hälfte kein kauen
ich möchte jetzt gerne probieren
Mama wie wäre es du bist benutzt immer
drei von denen dann nimmst du eins legst
es drauf und und die anderen zwei
schneidest Du hier entlang
dann gibt es nämlich immer jedes
Kuchenstück ist gleich groß
jetzt weiß ich was du meinst du legst es
da drauf und da entlang schneiden
Mercedes Kuchenstück gleich groß
Ingenieur
wirst du mal Erfinderin nein Ingenieur
nein
Steuerberater
und hier ja
ich glaube du nimmst eins mit kakaons
nein wie wäre es
halbieren hier das Kuchenteig du sollst
auf deine Seite Kakao nicht
habe ich dir heute schon gesagt dass ich
so stolz auf dich bin
richtig stolz auf dich du kannst schon
so viele Sachen
also hier ist die Hälfte oder ja
lass mich raten das ist mein Stück
oh mein Gott
dass du dich nicht verbrennst gut jetzt
probieren wir mal komm jetzt gucken wir
mal ob das der leckerste beste
schokoladigste Schokoladenkuchen auf der
Welt ist okay
es ist der beste
schokoladigste und leckerste
ist der so gut dass man gar nicht mehr
weiterreden kann wenn man das Reden
vergisst
na dann
also wenn die Ella jetzt ist okay gibt
das ist der beste Schokokuchen der Welt
ist dann findet ihr das Rezept ab jetzt
auf sallys-blog.de und in meiner App
backt den Kuchen gerne mal nach probiert
den aus wie gesagt ihr könnt ihr noch
gerne glutenfrei zubereiten ja
Ella empfiehlt den Kuchen perfekt also
viel Spaß beim backen bis zum nächsten
Mal
das war's dann wohl mit meiner Hälfte
ist okay ich habe das große Stück
ich darf eh nicht so viel
[Musik]